terrorists right now please stay right
here enjoy the crab rangoon don't move
I'll be right back Yuma We Need to Talk
[Music]
oh man bloody tastic you sir are a
gentleman I sincerely apologize we saw
terrorists in the area and yadda-yadda
the crab rangoon right it fabulous mm
well come on let's go
[Music]
three-point landing you know part of me
is surprised your mother asked for you
to bring her all the way back here thank
you
Cam'ron you want me to follow Jesus
Christ yes boy the ashes aren't going to
scatter themselves
did your mother ever tell you about her
father never know Mohan a great
protector of the Golden Path he was a
[ __ ] he hauled your mother out sent her
to spy on me but we fell in love we had
a child and that is when lohan showed
his true colors
he drove you and your mother away even
killed your sister
hochche mana which brings us here
Lakshmana shouldn't be alone anymore
I'm so glad we're finally back together
after you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh good you feel better now get it out
of your system
early maybe now we can finally shoot
some goddamn guns
[Music]
you
[Music]
darling you've got to let me know should
I stay or should I go
[Music]
if you say that you are mine
[Music]
dick
[Music]
[Music]